so you just saw pictures of what can
happen when
no one's enforcing the law and when the
mob rules
that has been the case on a much smaller
scale in parts of this country for more
than a year now
defunding the police is the term they
apply to it it's been a disaster
it's also deeply unpopular with voters
of all kinds
82 percent of americans oppose defunding
the police
but there are still some activists who
are committed to it regardless of what
the public wants in the name of
democracy of course
the police are racist they want to
eliminate them
what's interesting is what that looks
like up close so in oakland california
on saturday some of those same
anti-racist activists shouted down a
group of black demonstrators
who were out in public showing support
for police officers what a picture this
was watch
a white privilege of standing here thank
you
right here
you are not our people okay
hey black people how dare you support
the police
it's beyond belief really but it's real
burgess owens is a
republican member of congress from the
state of utah and we're happy to have
him with us congressman thanks so much
for coming on that video
kind of tells you a lot about the
current state of our political
conversation
what's your reaction to it i think it's
important that we
recognize uh tucker that this is uh not
by accident
uh you know the cultural marxists what
they thrive on is uh chaos
uh personal chaos people being made
miserable people living in fear
if you live in fear you can't run a
business you can't build your business
uh
build build your family uh spirituality
goes out the window
and that's how they win so what we've
seen this last year what you're seeing
right now in oakland all these places
that black and hispanic and uh at-risk
people are being hurt most
is by cultural marxists who care less
because they are godless
they uh could care less about the
capitalism of property
and they hate the nuclear family so
that's what we're up against we need to
recognize that
and really stand up strong for our
judeo-christian values the values that
made our country what it is
you know you're right they're godless
that is exactly right i never talk like
that but it's true
it's absolutely true when you say that
how do people respond
well they're those who get it most
americans get it
they might not speak as strong as i do
but they get it yeah and then those who
are
who trying to destroy our country they
they hate what i'm saying so
we just have to have the courage uh well
i was taught this very simply uh tucker
growing up
love god country family respect for
women and authority and we got it made
underneath that the common denominator
is courage we need to have courage so
uh americans know we're up against this
we need to fight against this evil
ideology that's trying to destroy us
divide us and we can do that no matter
what side what part of the line we're
part of
this make our country great for our kids
we need to fight against eagle to get
that done
god family country respect for women and
authority and you're good to go i'd say
that's right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else